he may run this one here's William
pumping looking taking his time all day
to throw it buys more time side on throw
and it's caught Washington across the
field hits the
sideline here's a play Fay Williams off
his back foot caught at the 30
Sanders takes his time lofs one in the
air caught touchdown
Colorado
Williams steps into his throw touchdown
Williams quick throw caught rice down
the sideline
Sanders steps up in the pocket runs it
gets it first down and more Sanders
spreading to the Ed Zone
touchdown Caleb
Williams over the middle touchdown Lloyd
back in play fake they dump it off in
the end zone touch coach W to see what
he's got on second
down chador Sanders finds Harrison
touchdown cross the field fourth down
and five Sanders Sprints out of the
pocket
looking touchdown of Maria Miller for
terrific receivers here's Sanders inzo
touchdown Jimmy hard